[Musique]
ici à aubigny sur nère la succession de
maisons à colombages est une partie des
vestiges de l'histoire écossaise de la
ville chaque année on célèbre l'amitié
avec les causses à l'occasion des fêtes
franco-écossaise plein d'erreurs ça sent
la douche écossaise franchement ramener
la pluie dans cet épisode spécial écosse
ça allait faire ça c'est de la grosse
production ccnucc france 3 centre val de
loire
vous connaissez des battles de rap est
bien ici on est à aubigny sur nère dans
le cher ici c'est l'amitié franco
écossaise ok donc battle minot cornemuse
candidat numéro 1 robert enfin avec
l'accent écossais web le candidat numéro
2 bastien allez c'est parti
[Musique]
a toujours l'impression que tu vas jouer
au rugby
bravo mr bastien bout
[Musique]
j'arrive plus à sortir du j'aime bien
les kilts mais là c'est quand même oui
c'est vrai que tu t'es coin c'est
carrément dans les pieds voilà ça te va
très bien tu pourras venir au fait
pourquoi écossaise avec le clip on va
parler justement de ce lien avec les
causes et aubigny ça remonte à la guerre
de cent ans mais 420 en pleine guerre de
cent ans et tout ce qui appartient la
couronne appartient charles vii et vos
billets est une ville qui appartient le
courant pour remercier j'instaure deux
derniers qui est venu avec 5000 écossais
pour pouvoir combattre les anglais il va
lui donner aux billets aux billets
devient une ville complètement écossaise
un peu comme aujourd'hui si tu veux
monaco on va parler aussi de la famille
stuart ses abords de la famille stuart
on avance sur s'autogère de cette
console de jeux de l'époque les chevaux
les bouger c'est trop dire alors on leur
remet la ville et qu'est ce qui se
passait en 1423 jans tort de tarder les
et qu'on est apte et cause bien sûr il
se bat en france aux côtés de charles
sykes et suite à la bataille de bon chez
les écossais vont pulvériser l'armée
envers allah les écossais sont
complètement pulvérisé la rue au delà
c'est comme la ville de linyi était une
ville de royal dont il lui a donné bien
en avoir une autre bataille pour les
deux ans après donc là c'est la version
numéro 2 la consonne la console a évolué
toujours en avance sur son temps charles
c'est pas les une dernière bataille
françois ça sera la journée des arts en
est malheureusement le saignant tommy
lee va nourrir malgré cette défaite les
sueurs quotidien est ce qu'il ya des
ambulances et la ville jusqu'au 17
jusqu'à l'époque de louis xiv on va
quand même aller voir la dame à qui la
vie elle était donnée madame de karwan
absolument c'est l'histoire est sordide
français mais tu rates ont tellement
bien
c'était ni la battle c'était juste comme
ça pour le début d'émission on se calme
et nec oui un jeu de regards et tout
donnant une invitée je vais pouvoir
après on a pas fini d histoire une
histoire de ligne et parce qu'on part de
madame de pirouelle et se termine avec
le prince william aubigny a été redonné
à louis xiv et vingtenaires louise de
keroual quand tu vois la descendance du
petit fils de louise de keroual du côté
de la fille et du garçon du deuxième duc
ils vont se remarier ensemble et dessous
qu est ce qu on voit apparaître les dj
voilà spencer future maman
tu nous vient d'où robert alors je suis
originaire de l'ecosse l'île de skye
lille le mans je m'appelle mec kansas l
accent écossais c'est sexy le kilt que
tu portes il a été fabriqué par
christelle ta compagne la petite
française est devenue la grande
fabricante de kiel pour le monde entier
elle en exporte par tour en australie
aux états unis en alaska bastien
bastienne le beau gosse tu nous vient
d'où je viens de châtillon sur loire
rien à voir avec l'école et comment tu
fais pour être aussi barak est aussi
svelte sa série de dix ans non à ses
fins le rugby et la cornemuse bah voilà
les coaches sur internet l'a fait de
manger des fruits macha grenon mu elle
opte essec été musclé comme bastien
voilà roberts bravo et merci bastien
pareil bravo et merci au nom mais sur
les pavés nerfs des gars de la date
indéterminée c'est l'amitié franco
écossaise la
tenue et je veux un clip christelle un
robot
bonsoir